en revanche les médicaments utilisés des
lotions des effets secondaires bien
qu'ils aient pu être recommandée et
approuvé par la nexen dans l'hymne est
solide dont l'équipe qui l'utilisé dans
un était français a rapporté qu'il y
avait 50% des effets secondaires dont
des néphropathies qui sont des attaques
perdre aux irréversible et z afin de
postuler à la version c'est un produit
très dangereux nous on avait utilisé il
ya quelques années il ya dix années
ensemble en compte que ça n'a évidemment
extrêmement bourges on peut utiliser
même le traitement de base de
tuberculose si elle arrive francs
piscine dans 5 % créer des effets
secondaires graves donc voilà
globalement le tabou des antituberculeux
qu'est ce qui se passe actuellement est
elle deux phénomènes qui se pose à nous
est chère que l'eau s'est tue encore un
million de ou un million six de
personnes
qu'est ce qui se passe à dire que l'audi
a2 problème premièrement il ya les tue
la clause résistante en particulier à la
région qui si les pourcel tuberculose
résistante l'ol mais ça fait un certain
nombre de propositions
parmi ces propositions il y à celle
d'utiliser évidemment qu'on les utilise
et la chauffe asie c'est sur le site de
l'ol mais c'est pas très compliqué
regardez donc c'est un médicament banal
dans les tuberculoses résistantes pour
des tuberculoses qui sont sensibles à
rennes chantepie s'il ya des questions
qui sont posées et très récemment qui
ont été posées par
notre maître à tous pour le recul c'est
pas les grosses et terrain parisien pour
la foutue dehors 65 ans et aux états
unis travailler pendant encore 25 ans et
qui a montré que c'était le médicament
qui habite qui était le plus efficace de
tout cela que l'os et qui permettait de
résoudre par un point très important
c'est la durée du traitement durée du
traitement naturel klaus et six mois et
avec la pop féminine il a montré là
aussi un financement spécifique à
laquelle l'institut de recherche qui a
publié les nerfs journaux du monde qui
montre que le plus facile est le seul à
stériliser rapidement les animaux
infectés je suis lassé les animaux les
modèles animaux des animaux infectés par
la tuberculose
donc on s'est posé la question nous
savoir thé qui se sait le alors tout
pour la coface imminent est ouverte aux
résistants il ya eu tout signé personnes
qui ont
des cas qui est publié dans la
littérature
de 13 ou 14 pays différents
et donc c'est le traitement qui marche
le mieux dans les cercles aux
résistances pour les filles avaient
ainsi proposé un projet de recherche ce
projet de recherche a été d'abord
accepter une première fois par un ctp
vers le comité de protection de
personnes vous savez c'est le groupe des
gens qui regardent si on peut ou ne peut
pas utiliser un produit qui a donné un
avis favorable à nsn a donné ensuite un
avis défavorable il nous a surpris parce
que normalement les sam n'a pas à donner
son avis sur l'utilisation de
médicaments qui sont qui sont dans le
vidal qui sont des médicaments
utilisable dans un repositionnement et
ensuite on a redéposé ce projet ce
projet a reçu à nouveau un avis
favorable du cpp à nouveau de l'année
scène sans explication nous a dit elle
voulait pas le faire je vous rappelle
que pendant ce temps l autoriser un
projet avec l'église holy qui donne 50 %
des effets secondaires donc en pratique
on n'a pas mis en place dès qu'on a eu
les
la ville annonce m donc personne n'a été
l'objet d'un essai thérapeutique depuis
que la nes elle nous a donné son ami et
personne n'avait donc combien les
argentiers peut-être été évité à ses
environs la première neige